alright guys bangbang I have the one and
only Preston here thanks for jumping on
and doing this dad no problem glad to be
here you have spent most of your career
as a lawyer so you actually can give
legal advice to clients but also tend to
be somebody who I think is a
constitutional proponent right in that
you believe the Constitution is
important and you believe that the
amendments there or are worth paying
attention to maybe give us a little bit
of your background and kind of what
you're doing today and then we could
jump into some of the nuances of what's
happening right now in the world sure so
I started my career as a securitization
lawyer so that's doing stuff for banks
back in the financial crisis basically
repackaging mortgages and things like
that and that was over in London England
after that I started a blockchain tech
company and got really into sort of
libertarian politics there's kind of
happened at the same time because if you
work for a big corporate law firm in the
middle of a major city they don't
exactly like having their junior
associates running around spouting off
libertarian opinions and criticizing the
government so that was a fortuitous
fortuitous development then then after
that I so I'd ran to who's called moan
axe it was a blockchain enterprise
blockchain company then after that went
back to law school here in the States
got reified as a lawyer here in the
states opened my own law firm which
focused on startups tech companies IP
issues just general corporate stuff for
small companies and just last month
actually on March 1st I moved down to
Washington DC to be a partner with
Stephen pally and Bob Cornish over
Anderson kill which is a big litigation
shop and we're building a sort of tech
focused corporate practice there and of
course two then two weeks later I had to
leave because I'm kovin so I ran right
back up to to Connecticut and and Here I
am and so looking forward to getting
back to it whenever the country opens
back up for sure so what I want to start
I think is maybe talk a little bit of
just about what is libertarian politics
I don't think I've ever heard that term
explain that a little bit sure so I mean
you know libertarianism right
generally so for your listeners
libertarianism is you know all the Ron
Paul memes that's libertarianism for
those of you who live on the internet
but general is being libertarianism is a
political ideology which holds that
individuals an individual agency are
really the most important thing for a
happy and successful life and our
political arrangements and government
and law and elsewhere should reflect
that and basically minimal minimize the
amount of interference that third
parties or the state has with individual
life so as a practical matter what
you'll see generally are low taxes is a
policy that libertarians with tend to
espouse or no taxes decrypt mass
decriminalization of drugs and things
like that because it's an element of
personal choice decriminalization of
weed is a very libertarian policy to
hold and then there are others which are
a little more contentious but you know
in the purist libertarian sense they
would be very open borders very free
markets very no regulation so they would
say listen go build your factories
overseas there's also a nationalist
stream which runs through some aspects
of libertarianism which tends to say
well listen we actually need to work it
look out for workers and be a little
more strategic about how we arrange our
supply lines I tend to be more of that
than the total absolutist libertarian
but it's a big church it's a big tent
and there's there's room for all kinds
of people on it
got it and so how does that play into
today's world when you have got a health
crisis going on with kovat 19 you then
also have an economic crisis that's kind
of the fallout of the response to the
health crisis how are most libertarians
kind of viewing what's going on and kind
of what do they think is good and what
do they wish maybe it's not happening
there's a great meme you may have seen
it money printer Gober and what happens
is there's a guy there two stick figures
two NPC woad acts and one of them is
losing his mind and and actually is not
a blowback it's just the NBC and so he's
losing his mind and he's wearing a bow
tie which is black and yellow which was
the traditional libertarian or
anarcho-capitalist colors and he's
freaking out he's like oh my god the
feds printing money for a purpose and
then the next frame over there's a guy
sitting there and he goes haha money
printed goober and it's just printing
money off like crazy so libertarians are
basically all losing our minds because
this is we're in peak State this is the
state at the absolute apex of its power
in an emergency where it has the maximum
freedom of action and this is even in
the United States in dire emergencies so
we're talking about asteroid impact
nuclear war pandemic plague in those
instances the state has enormous powers
in rebellion insurrection the state has
enormous powers to step into ordinary
life and pass edicts which would not be
legal under ordinary or constitutional
and would be readily challengeable under
normal circumstances got it and so I
guess let's start with some of those
constitutional aspects right we're
seeing things that I think most people
are just jumping up and down and saying
wait a minute time out how is this legal
so everything from the prevention of
freedom of assembly so literally you
can't have more than you know ten people
or five people all in one location
things like the state of Rhode Island
saying we are going to use the police
and military to patrol transportation
centers in order to identify people who
come from other cities or states and
then even things like in Kentucky we've
seen a judge order somebody who refused
to stay in quarantine to wear a
gps-enabled ankle bracelet these all
seem you know at best sensitive topics
at worst complete violations of the
Constitution how do you kind of think
through them and like what are the
frameworks you use to evaluate these
situations sure so sorry my computer fan
is running and I'm not sure why so I'm
gonna turn the heat off I just do that
here so so what so how do we look at
this so in we have constitutional rights
in the United States everyone's familiar
with what those rights are those rights
include they can't deprive you of life
liberty or property without due process
of law ie a court hearing they can't the
Congress can't make any rules or any
governmental agency for that matter
can't make rules which tell you what you
are and aren't allowed the things which
you are and aren't allowed to say you
know what
what opinions you can and can't express
that kind of stuff so that's the First
Amendment however in certain
circumstances
the courts will authorize a otherwise
and presumptively unconstitutional
arrangement or rule if a it is necessary
for a to further a compelling government
interest go in the boat that means in a
second and B it is no wider and a
broader than is necessary to accomplish
that interest and that's known as strict
scrutiny review so what happens is if
the if the state creates a rule and let
us suppose just for sake of argument New
York says if Governor Cuomo is really
having a bad day and he writes an
executive order and the executive order
says I hereby ban all of the things
Andrew Cuomo and he goes and issues that
order it's a quarantine right but just
because there's a quarantine on doesn't
mean he has the power to ban everything
it means that he has the power to
address a compelling government interest
right and he can't go any further than
is necessary to address that interest so
what that means is in you know if we
have a society-wide catastrophe such as
a pandemic the scope of that can be very
broad indeed but once this is once the
emergency receives ideally those rules
are going to start to become
unconstitutional and hopefully they'll
be revoked before they have to be
challenged what are the odds that they
actually get revoked pretty good I think
most of so most of the orders that we've
seen are so economically damaging that I
don't actually so as a libertarian there
are a lot of people who are freaking out
about in in libertarian circles about
the use of government power there is one
instance the other day where I was in
the deterrence dispensed key-based
Channel and one guy was like oh no
they're declaring Martial Law I said no
we're not declaring Martial Law
what happens is yes the National Guard
is being brought in to set up hospitals
but the military has not been given
administration of law enforcement the
civilian courts are still open the
civilian police are still operating
we're still under civilian rules
answering to civilians political
officers no no it's martial law it's
this it's that which of course it isn't
this is totally normal civilian order
it's very extreme civilian order but it
is to do an order now the damage that
these the economic damage that this
quarantine is doing is so substantial
that I have to imagine that the states
will want to roll
fact the minute they possibly can for
political expediency if nothing else so
I don't think a lot of that is going to
last what might last are some
supervision problems around health care
so and maybe at the borders there might
be increased surveillance there and of
course the US has you know has an
extensive surveillance regime domestic
and international domestically we have a
lot of protections built into law to
prevent that stuff from being leaked to
the government and then used against you
in a criminal proceeding or part of a
criminal investigation so there are
instances of course we've heard I don't
know if you've heard of the term
parallel construction but parallel
construction is a term which refers to
the practice of intelligence officials
giving information and law enforcement
which kind of hints which allows them to
find something which they can then build
a valid chain of evidence from in order
to secure a conviction normally if
you're gathering evidence or criminal
prosecution the rule is if it's fruit of
the poisonous tree you can't introduce
it against the defendant so if for
example you have an illegal let's say
you break into some of your cop right
and you think a guy is has a bunch of I
don't know yeah you think a guy's like
abusing is I don't know try to find a
good one abusing his cat right and so
what you decide to do is you see the cat
on the front lawn and you decide you're
gonna break into the house and search
the entire house top to bottom including
his underwear drawers and in the
underwear drawer you find a gram of
cocaine in that hypothetical if you're
investigating the abuse of a cat and you
know where the cat is looking in an
underwear drawer which is this big and
finding a gram of cocaine is way way way
in excess of what was necessary in order
to conduct that search if you do it
without a warrant if you did it with a
warrant it would probably be specified
in the warrant you're going here to go
look for evidence of abuse of the cat
finding the cat alive and well is
probably you know a good indicator that
the least it's not happening at that
moment but then going and digging into
other things that are unauthorized you
would then be unable to go and introduce
that baggie of cocaine or you could
introduce it but what the defendant
would then do is say listen the police
exceeded their authorizations here there
are similar rules in place for digital
searches and digital seizures where
judicial authorization pre-authorization
required before data is handed over the
government I think it'll be interesting
to see whether health data is exempted
from that and and how and if so how so
for example we're seeing Google now sang
lists and we're tracking people's phones
and we're giving the government
information during generalized
information about where people are the
government cannot constitutionally
cannot obtain individualized location
data from Google on any person without a
search warrant which which specifies the
person is issued on probable cause and
is time limited in terms of duration so
I don't think there's a big so a lot of
libertarians will freak out about
something like that that's a concern for
sure but I think it's more of a concern
that we hand over data to Google anyway
which they can then go and willy-nilly
do with as they please because there are
procedural and protect protections in
place that are Fourth Amendment style
that prevent Google from giving that's
at state god it's something like the
Google tracking tool which I think a lot
of people feel at least uncomfortable
about basically as long as it is
aggregate and anonymized then it's
probably okay but if for some reason
they started to say here is exactly
where precedent has been and handed
that's the government that's where the
issues could be introduced well I mean
so you're creating the record as you go
right so a telephone these records exist
they're being held excuse me they're
being held on Google servers and other
servers you know and other companies
servers around the world right now those
companies can do whatever really
whatever they want with that data I
don't think they can release it to the
general public they cannot give it to
the government but it is there so if the
government decided it wanted to initiate
some kind of investigation and track
where your movements are even though it
can't go out and get that data
willy-nilly it needs to have a reason to
see it that record does exist and also
that record just one thing that we we
say in data security land is that the
best way to prevent a data security
breach is just to not hold the records
never generate the records otherwise
once you've generated it basically it's
a honeypot and so it's a it's a big
target for some hacker or state actor or
someone else to try to obtain so as
we're generating all this information
about ourselves and that information is
being fed into these big companies it's
creating these vast repositories
which the government can readily access
they need a reason to do it and they
need a reasonable art you know
particularized suspicion or a reasonable
is it a reasonable suspicion a probable
cause excuse me any probable cause to
believe that a crime has occurred which
is a higher standard than reasonable
reasonable suspicion if guilt if
absolute like undoubtable undoubtedly
guilty is you know saw the guy do it is
a hundred percent and the probable cause
is probably somewhere around forty or
fifty percent probability
whereas reasonable suspicion I'd say in
terms of just the general feel you can't
quantify it but that's how that works so
so anyway that's that's kind of my view
on on that we're creating these vast
blues data the government's likely to
want to get a hold of it they will need
to pass new legislation to do it so
we're gonna have to take a very close
look at what legislation is introduced
in order ensure that they don't stay
over seven hours and then how do we
think about this when it comes to like
individually the effect on mere you and
say them ordering us to wear a mask for
example like where is the constitutional
boundaries there and is it something
that people should be worried about yet
or are we still pretty much operating in
you know okay territory so it's into
territory right because we're new
territory I don't think the federal
government could order someone to wear
masks just to start the states on the
other hand have a very broad police
power so a lot of sovereign powers when
the US has four members they're reserved
to the states under the Tenth Amendment
and one of those is the police powers so
you'll note that as these quarantine
sold out across the country where
countries like China just like you know
convened the Politburo and the Politburo
gave an order and then the whole country
followed the order in the US it's been a
very decentralized response there are
pluses and and negative negatives to
that on the plus side the states that
were hit early and they acted early
appeared to have blunted you know their
infection rates Washington California DC
for example all DC was closed like a
week and a half before everybody else
was I think New York closed on the 21st
of March but by sort of March 11th all
of the federal agencies had sent their
workers home all of those mrs. Primm
courted closed Congress had closed the
parks have closed everything is closed
so I think maybe that's because DC had a
pretty good idea
was coming in York didn't but that's TBD
so those those jurisdictions within the
Federation which closed down early are
coming out of it a little earlier
generally speaking and with less damage
and they know their jurisdictions well
they know their territories they know
what works and what doesn't work
and so we've seen actually a really
efficient response so New York for
example the Javits Center was converted
into a mobile into a field hospital and
then they brought in the USNS comfort or
mercy one of the big hospital ships I
think they've had 110 patients and today
for tomorrow is when their their surge
peak is supposed to happen so they
managed using their local knowledge and
local command and control to be very
effective in containing the outbreak and
and eliminating it so and hopefully
eliminating it it's you know if
everything goes according to plan but it
was local fundamentally and the states
have a lot of power locally when they
when they want to act in an emergency
when the emergency subsides though that
power goes away yeah and I guess then
this also goes into them limiting like
the freedom of assembly right so hey you
literally can't come together except
show that it seems like it's all coming
from the state not so much from the
federal government as well yeah so
they're in some states and federal
government with regard to freedom of
assembly are bound by the same rules
right they have the same constraints
generally speaking it gives so again
this is a fundamental right so it's not
going to be you're not able to restrain
it unless you meet this strict scrutiny
standard of review furthermore we have
something so basically we have something
with free speech and assembly and those
types of political rights express in
political rights the kinds of
restrictions which are allowable will
generally be referred to as time place
and manner restrictions so for example
they'll say you know you can protest and
say whatever you want but you know you
can't do it between you know 2 a.m. and
4 a.m. outside of an old folks home
right or and you also have to when
you're restricting free speech rights in
particular you have to leave open
multiple alternative avenues for that
expression to take place and you can't
discriminate or be content based on on
who you're closing and why so if for
example let's look at churches that's
been a really contentious one so
churches have been ordered closed
there's gathering spaces as part of
these orders if you said only
Rastafarian churches may remain open or
only synagogues must closed if you did
that then that was that's not going to
fly because the state isn't allowed to
make those kinds of decisions and
discriminate on that basis what the
rules of general application which
satisfies strict scrutiny and don't
discriminate are the kind of rules which
are going to going to fly and when it
comes to speech and expression and
assembly and other things we again we
run those same tests and we ask
ourselves necessary for a compelling
government interests and narrowly
tailored to address that interest and we
ask there're other evidence the answer
is yes there are so the government here
is not really it's in print yes it is
infringing on freedom of speech it is
infringing on freedom of assembly
it is infringing on your ability to
practice religion the way you want but
it's not without precedent that these
things happen so for example as I can't
remember the name of the case it's not
my head but there was a federal case
back in the day where a Native American
group out west sued the government
saying we should be allowed to take
peyote which is illegal as part of our
religious ceremonies and this law that
you passed that bans it is
unconstitutional they said well listen
no it's not unconstitutional because
it's a general application it's not
targeting you and so you're just gonna
have to live with it contrast that with
he la ever since I think it's Sarasota I
want to know what is it sorry Sheila was
from there the case yeah versus that's
the name of the case Aquila is the case
it is a a Rastafarian Church that
practiced animal sacrifice and so what
happened was the city passed the health
ordinance which prohibited the which
prohibited the sort of slaughtering of
live animals which was targeted but the
only place that that was targeted the
starter that was that one church so that
would wound up not satisfying
constitutional scrutiny so so when we
look at these ordinances that we're all
living under now we have to ask
ourselves all right you know it is if
there's an unconstitutional infringement
on our freedom we know what it's going
to look like it's going to target
specific groups it's going to target
specific minorities and it's going to
last longer than it needs to and it's
going to cover more circumstances than
it needs to
if they said you're you for example an
unconstitutional edict in a quarantine
situation would be you are prohibited
from worshipping at home you are
prohibiting from worshiping God period
that's an unconstitutional edict under
quarantine when the when the when the
quarantine subsides after all this is
over all of a sudden the other orders
might become unconstitutional because
they're presumptively unconstitutional
anyway but only the emergency renders
the Constitution got it and I guess one
of the cases or incidents that to me
seems incredibly complex and I not a
lawyer so I don't understand that
complexity is the man in Brooklyn who
had the FBI basically raided his house I
think his warehouse and there was a
couple of things that I took away from
it so one is they questioned him about
hoarding medical supplies and price
gouging they claimed that he lied to
them so come there's this lying to
federal officials component to it
there's a second claim that the actual
hoarding of the medical supplies was a
was not right and the third one was he
coughed in their direction when they
approached him and they basically
charged him with like attempted assault
or something and to me that's not an
attempted assault that is assault a song
okay so like to me what you end up
getting is you get this weird world
where it sounds like there's a lot of
interpretation right you know at what
point is it hey you coughed towards me
or on me versus you coughed around me
and you get some of that stuff so I
don't understand how legally that gets
defined but then also to is there's one
argument that you see online that says
hey the FBI just went to the private
property of an individual there's
another argument that says hey [ __ ]
stop hoarding you know much medical
supplies that people need and they went
they basically confiscated it and then
redistributed hospitals so I guess you
know fully under the umbrella of like
this is super complex and I'm assuming
at some point a court of law makes
decisions like how do you just think
through that type of scenario so there
are there are three problems that that
bedfellow had and we'll start with the
easiest one never talk to the FBI I
better respect for the really I mean
like I have a lot of respect for the FBI
they're extremely professional they deal
with some of the most difficult problems
you could possibly imagine and really
really very
very difficult subject matter but you
shouldn't talk to them without the
assistance of counsel if it is entirely
possible to have a lawyer in a
conversation with the FBI and be very
fully cooperative with the FBI and have
an interaction which ends well for both
sides but it's really important that you
have the lawyer there the reason it's
important is because for example in
general Mike Flynn he was interviewed by
the FBI as part of the the Russia hoax
is a Russia investigation if you don't
think it was a hoax and he misremembered
something right and if you tell a fib to
the FBI guess what that's a crime
we tell a fib to a federal officer
that's a crime so you should have a
lawyer in the loop whenever you're
having those discussions not because you
know you shouldn't not because
cooperating is a bad idea in the you
know especially in aid of national
emergency
but because cooperating is these guys do
this for a living and you don't and so
you can manage this five by being having
a professional in the loop and making
sure that that conversation is being
managed appropriately the second issue
is the coughing and that you know coffee
that's coughing in someone's direction
is a threat of sorts it's also an
assault you know when in the context of
the disease it'll be a question of fact
for a Trier of fact to decide so a judge
or a jury to really determine whether
whether that was in fact what he did and
then the third element is the seizure of
the medical supplies and so the
Constitution envisioned envisages that
seizures will happen but it says that
people will not be deprived their
property without just compensation right
so they're entitled to be compensated
for the property which is taken from
them so international I'm sure there's a
I'm not familiar with the federal you
know seizure regulations but generally
speaking the federal government has the
power to regulate interstate commerce
one to interstate commerce is a very
broad designation which applies to
pretty much anything that's crossed the
state line so unless the guy grew cotton
in his backyard then turn around and
forged weaved that cotton himself into
masks look plastic that I don't know he
made out of his toenails and then sold
it you know in cardboard box from the
tree he has in his garden that he
processed himself it's very likely that
these masks that he purchased from
somewhere else were done either over the
internet and therefore as part of
interstate commerce so first they have
the right to enter to intervene in
interstate
converse which means deal with things
like math supplies second they have
things second they have the ability to
seize property but you have to be
compensated it's a it's a taking the
Constitution makes very specific
provisions for condemnation and takings
and so so what I you know if I had been
in his situation the the preferable
thing to do is listen the FBI's showing
up they want your medical equipment shut
up call your attorney and the attorney
talked to the special agent in charge
and say alright listen you take the
equipment we're gonna expect to be
compensated we'll send you the bill and
then we can negotiate over over how much
we should be compensated and after this
is all done maybe we go to court and
have some litigation over it the
solution is not to turn around and start
screaming and saying my constitutional
rights because your constitutional
rights this is an emergency your rights
the government is at the absolute apex
of its power as long as this emergency
continues which means they go right
sometimes have to get put on the back
burner but they can't just take your
stuff and not compensate you right at
some point you're going to get
compensated for it might not be today it
might not be tomorrow it might be in six
months I've been here but you will be
compensated under those circumstances
yeah it's really interesting I want to
push a little bit further on like the
coughing thing so like you know I think
an extremist view would be why don't
they just outlaw coughing in public
right you know it's not something that
just seems absurd but in today's day and
age where literally people are scared if
they see someone cough in public like
how far does the either state or
national powers go for them to basically
try to change behavior when it comes to
medical crisis like this and it involves
specifically coughing could spread a
virus interesting I don't know about the
mask stuff is really untested and
untried it'll be interesting to see if
states start fining people for it and
then whether though whether they convene
the state legislatures to go past these
laws you know usually in the US actually
we have anti mask laws so in Virginia
for example wearing a mask without good
cause is a felony so you go to jail for
a long time if you do that and those
were enacted actually to counteract that
the one we called the clam running
around you know in there and they're
bedsheets you know
night things that are on fire so that of
course is not a very nice thing and now
of course they're reversing that
position and saying well now you must
wear masks for public health reasons
so masks have been considered within the
realm of State's abilities to legislate
and dictate human conduct before in
terms of prohibiting them so I think
it's not too far-fetched to imagine that
they may require people to wear them if
they're in crowded spaces or something
like that at least as a temporary
emergency measure for sure and then I
guess this brings us to businesses rates
a lot of what we've talked about so far
so on the individual level but at the
business level how would does the
Constitution or other laws apply in
terms of like government mandated
shutdowns and kind of a lot of what
we're seeing that's driving that
economic slowdown a lot of it is coming
mandated from either state or federal
government like what applies there yeah
businesses are not businesses don't
really enjoy the same extent of of
political rights as individuals they do
enjoy some political rights so for
example citizens united businesses have
the ability to make donations to packs
and more or less unlimited amounts
however because they operate in a
regulated space it's not really the same
as suggesting that you know so for
example if you had a let's say you had
some really dangerous business like a
garbage dump and someone do you ever had
a Licensing Authority and all the rest
of it and they had the ability to come
in and inspect they don't need a search
warrant to come in and inspect your
premises because you're operating in
this highly regulated space so as far as
the Fourth Amendment is concerned they
can come in look around to kind of tell
you what to do
Institute codes tell you what to do and
and bought and manage and and govern
your conduct a little more tightly than
they could for in private individual who
has and just happens to have a big tract
of land and a pile of junk in his
backyard right so or pile of junk in his
basement so for example they wouldn't be
able to come in to his house so rights
apply differently to different types of
persons so to speak rather than rather
than people so corporate persons or
businesses operate in more regulated
space I don't really see too much of a
political problem as long as there is a
non-discrimination you know in terms of
what the business owners or the
businesses themselves
espouse for from a political standpoint
here we're looking at blanket orders
that apply to everybody irrespective of
who is who is at at the helm of a
particular business if we started to see
discrimination of any kind
right so racial sexual political doesn't
matter
then we start to move into territory
where the government's orders would have
to be re-examined but at the moment
they're just blanket orders and they're
done for public health reasons at a time
when the state is at the apex its power
so it's it has to go away for economic
reasons I think the states want to do
but I don't see a legal problem really
got it and then I guess is there
anything we talked about the state power
that they can do like closing their
borders right so could New York State
say hey if you're from another state you
can't come here if you're another
business in another state you can't do
commerce with someone from our state
like is there anything that they can do
at the border level with individual
states
well there's legally probably not
practically probably I heard a story of
some friends friends of friends from New
York who decided they were going to get
away from all of this in West Virginia
and they were stopped and turned around
at the West Virginia border by a West
Virginia State Trooper apparently so
this is so in Rhode Island for example I
think that's a better example because
they were pretty clear initially Rhode
Island said we don't want so the
People's Republic of Rhode Island is
right next door to Connecticut it's
about 30 miles from where I am right now
it's a lovely little State it's got
great sailing great restaurants whatever
else very cute very quintessentially New
England and they decided they didn't
want any orcas coming up and spreading
the virus in their state so they said
anyone from New York with New York
plates it's going to be pulled over
stopped on their way into the Rhode
Island and then they're going to be
ordered to self quarantine for 14 days
they then change that order and they
said actually anybody from out of the
state who's traveling into the state and
it's coming here from out of the state
is going to be required to to to to self
quarantine for 14 days now the reason
they changed it I suspect is because we
have something called the privileges and
immunities clause of the Constitution
which says basically that one state
can't discriminate against the citizens
of another state so you can't say in
Rhode Island we're passing the law which
says that Rhode Islanders are
to smoke weed but anyone from New York
and possession of weed is going to jail
right that's not that's not how this
works if you're going to extend certain
privileges to your own citizens it has
to be for everybody you have to
uniformly apply the laws and also also
the Equal Protection Clause of the
Fourteenth Amendment would apply to that
so Rhode Island my suspicion is they did
the thing against New Yorkers someone
went dude 14th Amendment says you can't
do that they're like oh shoot they
decided to amend it when they amended it
and they'd turn around said well now it
applies to everybody no matter where
they're from even if they're from Rhode
Island if they're coming in from out of
state they must self quarantine for 14
days and so that would be likely to
withstand constitutional not likely it
would be more likely to withstand
constitutional scrutiny the other
problem is that crossing state borders
is fundamentally a federal issue
so in Delaware for example I know that
they shut down the state roads and they
were closing state roads and telling
people from out of state you can't drive
around in our state roads but they
weren't doing it on the interstates
which are maintained by the federal
government so everybody's always asked
well what would happen and in contagion
right that movie with Matt Damon
so in that movie that closed down the
interstates that closed down all the
state borders they didn't do that this
time they didn't do that in the real and
we have to ask ourselves why I suspect
it's because the plague wasn't deadly
enough and I think probably it would
have happened if it had been you know 25
percent CFR then you know maybe even
those constitutional provisions would
have been toward suspending but also the
federal system in the state system you
know the states can't turn around and
start discriminating against federal
traffic in Connecticut we have that
issue with tolling and our so they want
to introduce tolls on our roads and they
want to toll out-of-state drivers only
but not in-state drivers of course you
can't do that because that's an unfair
burden of Interstate Commerce
it's discriminating and citizens of
other states all kinds of constitutional
issues with it and so people have been
going back and forth on whether tolls
should be implemented or instituted here
in Connecticut the same thing applies
when you're looking at border controls
you could if a governor mistake could
conceivably order a stay at home owner
and say listen everybody in Connecticut
must not leave their homes except for
essential travel which we have the
effect of not permitting people to go
travel to other states it will not
essential because it wouldn't be allowed
on that state's roads but it can't be
some
which discriminates against other
citizens Florida has discriminated they
said any flights from Connecticut or New
York must self quarantine I think
actually they banned flights from
Connecticut New York and then anyone who
managed to get in through I mean who
wouldn't want people from Connecticut in
their state we are just the most
wonderful nice you know we've got a
really high per capita GDP we where you
see her sucker and man tuck a tread and
boat shoes I don't get it but somehow
these other states decided they didn't
want us around it's it's mind-blowing
that they didn't want our presence
didn't want to be graced by our presence
in their states but like I see where
they were coming from because
Connecticut is actually now more of a
hot spot I think than New York in
certain respects because Fairfield
County which is adjacent to New York got
swamped with New Yorkers leaving New
York and so as a consequence they're a
little bit earlier in the curve than the
rest of the Northeast including New York
City and New Jersey so you know I get it
I see what people are doing it I doubt
there will be litigation arising from it
because it's basically it's moot and no
one's going to care but they couldn't
travel through Rhode Island so it's not
really worth their time money to bring
the case maybe we'll get one but I
suspect the case would be dismissed
remove this yeah and I guess can they do
something where they say will allow like
food deliveries right or some sort of
supply chain type transportation but we
will allow what all codes are like
retail or residential travel I guess
like you as an individual are applied
different rules than let's say a
corporation trying to actually get
supplies whether they're medical or
non-medical yeah so when you read these
orders most of the orders carve out when
they referred a non-essential travel
they're really referring to people who
live in the state so in terms of
trucking and things like that trucking
is not affected food deliveries are not
affected and that's primarily because
it's not the states it's not really
within the state's power to do it
because that's a federal issue the
Commerce Clause says that Congress is
the power to regulate that in all the
states so if the states did say listen
we're closing our borders and no
trucking is allowed in I suspect me to
get a tap on the shoulder from President
Trump or at least one of the Department
of Justice's attorneys saying all right
well we can get we can get an injunction
and prevent you from doing that in like
two seconds flats maybe you want to
reconsider that policy so I don't think
we're gonna
anything like that unless really the
federal government would have to be on
board with that in order for that to
happen and even so you would see
emergency lawsuits almost immediately if
that level of lockdown were instituted
got it for business owners themselves
whether their technology companies you
founders venture capital back type
companies or small businesses what are
the things that they should be thinking
through right now from a legal
perspective and both from a reporting
but also operating their business and
all of the federal funds that are
flowing exceptional like how are you
talking to clients about that right now
yeah you know most most clients were a
little most people were a little
shell-shocked in the first two weeks of
this right so except for the people
who've been prepping like crazy I have
one I'm one client who's also property
whatever don't care she's gonna keep
building my business so I have some of
those clients I like those clients very
much other businesses depending on where
they are kind of in their funding cycle
you'll see businesses that are currently
in the middle of raising you if now is
not a great for obvious reasons now is
not a great time to raise so businesses
that are raising are obviously looking
they're staring down the barrel of a gun
and so they've had to make some pretty
some of them event that I know of him
had to make some very aggressive moves
in terms of staff cuts and other things
and pay cuts you name it and applying
for SBA assistance and all the rest of
it in order to push out their runway to
a point where they're comfortable that
they'll be able to raise around during
the intervening period businesses that
are revenue neutral are obviously in
fairly good shape businesses that have
storefronts and other things are
obviously not particularly good shape so
that's especially if they're not
digitally enabled so they're struggling
really to deal with like taking orders
over the phone and things like that so
you know for example in my town we have
a local butcher and that's where we go
do most of our shopping and so they're
it's like they're taking orders over the
phone they could have a web app which
would do all this really well they're
just not keyed up for it and so it just
doesn't exist so maybe in the future
we'll and then generally speaking
businesses that are well funded just
kind of they're sitting back there
waiting there's there may be holding off
on some discretionary legal spending so
we've seen some things where as an
attorney of course someone comes in
you know like well I want to sue that
guy they're like cool awesome like let's
go like let's get started I'm happy to
start running that clock and going after
this guy for you and sometimes you see
people coming in with really strong
claims and this can even be with like
business interruption insurance right
and they'll say listen we we know that
we have this insurance policy and we
know that we want to make this claim but
right now is not the time to throw down
a retainer and strut counsel I began
moving forward so we've seen a lot of
companies that even if they're in a
decent cash flow position they don't
know the uncertainty is preventing them
from actually initiating those actions
when things become a little more certain
and very much expecting that those those
will turn into very concrete pieces of
litigation or deal-making or whatever
else needs to be done and there's gonna
be a bit of a backlog to to address it
so that's kind of the range if you're if
you're venture funded and you're running
out of runway
everyone's slamming on the brakes firing
all the people and and and preparing for
the worst if your venture funded and
you've got plenty of runway then you
know you're in pretty good shape and
people are just kind of sitting back
writing it out and positioning and
particularly software companies this is
a huge opportunity for software
companies to start disrupting
paper-based or continue I should say
disrupting paper-based businesses there
are a whole bunch of different video
conferencing software that's coming out
so we're on zoom' right now zoom has
taken a lot of heat from the US
government from Google from the state of
New York
personally gab comm is launching one
next week called on gab which is just
totally totally soui generous new
offering where you don't even need a gab
account because I've taken a look at it
I've taken it for a test drive it's
pretty cool so I'm looking forward to
that and some other things and and yeah
I mean it's it's gonna be really
interesting to see where where things go
but I don't think it looks like this is
gonna wrap up at least for certain parts
of the country in three or four weeks
we're gonna start reopening again
gradually slowly and companies will have
a better idea of where they sit in
landscape yeah are there any things that
change in the way that kind of legally
that the companies operate taxes and
anything that you see there that's like
a pothole fish need to be aware of or is
it pretty much a lot of it is more
no for three or four weeks until the
kind of the dust settles I think that
it'll be interesting to see what happens
with rent abatements ordered by States I
think that those are probably
constitutionally questionable because
they are takings so the landlord's can't
simply have their rent taken away
without just compensation there are
common law contractual mechanisms that
people are going to start to invoke
particularly if these rents sort of and
and long term contracts drag on that
they can't avail themselves of so I
expect there's gonna be a lot of
fighting over that there's probably a
lot of rent being withheld there's
probably a lot of evictions that have
been suspended and so there's gonna be a
very big backlog of work clear all of
that so that that I think is gonna be
the big one is kind of starting to
reconcile all the payments that haven't
been made but when when America finally
comes out of this all that
reconciliation is gonna start happening
the other thing I think that the prudent
businesses will do although not all
businesses when I ran a small law firm I
always make sure I had three to six
months of runway in the bank right so
that's it was it was I considered it a
luxury to have that but basically my
first billing cycles as an independent
lawyer I was like cool I'm not taking a
draw this month I'm not taking a draw
that I want to make sure that I have
enough effects that if the phone doesn't
ring for you know 180 days I'm still I
can go into the office sit there twiddle
my thumb's ship post on Twitter and and
and I can go home and sleep at night
right so that to do that you had to be
really really frugal at the beginning of
the practice and also I couldn't do
things like I wasn't running my practice
out of a we work in Manhattan I
deliberately made the choice to qualify
in Connecticut instead of New York
because I would get admitted more
quickly and the real estate is cheaper
and so basically I could set up this
little sort of practice in the middle of
nowhere for not a lot of money and then
service tech clients essentially both
from the middle of the woods which is
pretty cool so that that kind of
arrangement where you have maybe
satellite offices or you start moving
people into smaller towns out of New
York so you have a little more inbuilt
resiliency I think we're gonna see more
of that particularly if there's a second
wave of this in the fall and the cities
once again have to close down these
businesses are not going to want to be
operating or vulnerable exposed exposed
to cities I think now we see that it's
not enough to simply have all
in different cities right so if you have
if you have a company you've got offices
in Boston New York DC Philadelphia San
Francisco and Houston right all of your
offices are currently closed and all of
your people are currently locked in
their apartments so they're not really
able to do too much if you have offices
in Wyoming guess what
chances are you people can go in and
they can run a printer do whatever else
take phone calls so I think that I think
Wyoming has closed all non-essential
businesses but if you've got a one-man
office or something like that for a
while you could go in and do those
things so it'll be interesting to see
how people decide to allocate their
resources after this because exposure to
cities is now a new new category of risk
and so I think people are gonna want
diversify away from that for sure
before I finish up anything on the
crypto front that he thinks don't worthy
or worth paying attention to
yeah I'm gonna crypto front that's
everything has been coded so I just have
been looking at good though too closely
the big one I think was the telegram the
biggest thing of the last month or two
was the telegram litigation so what
happened was telegram the sec sorry the
sec applied for a preliminary injunction
against telegram to restrict them or to
restrain them from distributing ton
tokens to us and global investors
telegram then countered and said listen
we should at least be able to distribute
to overseas investors under reg ass you
know so they can go and trade these
things and do whatever and forget but
the US issued alongside
the court stepped in and said actually
no our view the courts view was that the
entire telegram scheme right the coin
the marketing the sassed all of it
together constituted the security right
and that's a really big kind of Catholic
small C Catholic view of how these
transactions should be regulated so Jay
Clayton and the SEC to date haven't
really asked for that they haven't
really regulated on the basis that
that's the case so if we've seen for
example aetherium totally got a free
pass and was allowed 100 percent through
despite the fact that it was very
clearly conducted as a Nicaea and as an
investments in program right they just a
little it's proof of work we're not
going to pay attention to it we're not
interested well if I got to EOS and
block one you're looking at something
which has a little more
security like it's launched in 2017 and
at the big Bitcoin conference in New
York there's a billboard in Times Square
they get dinged or the 24 million dollar
fine the SEC doesn't really require too
much further other than that then we get
the telegram and kick for example which
are the two big ones that are fighting
in court and they're saying well you
didn't enforce against all these guys
you know we're just doing the same thing
except we you know we've sold it under
staffs and the tokens are what people
own whatever the courts that actually
know we're gonna take a really big view
this a very wide view of this and
incorporate the entire scheme within the
definition of security and if that's the
case it basically means that there is no
ICL market you know the United States
now or ever so you'll have to proof of
work coins I think or whatever that
might look like proof of work issuance
is likely to take precedence going
forward over prove mistake prove mistake
has some other issues you know around
securities laws house taking is treated
from an investment contract perspective
but basically the u.s. is sent a really
clear signal that if you want to roll a
cryptocurrency you can do you want to
mine it you can but you have to be doing
something which is structured like
Bitcoin and not structured like like a
block one ioser or telegram sale that's
the big news of the month sounds good
for Bitcoin yeah every everything is
good for Bitcoin always absolutely
before we finish up favorite book ever
the same Society by Erich Fromm Erich
Fromm was a psychoanalyst who practiced
in Germany back in like the 1930s and
40s and 50s and he was also a Marxist
philosopher so he parted with known as
the Frankfurt School of critical theory
and so what he did was he sought to
understand psychology and psychological
issues that his patients suffered and
that ordinary people suffered in the
context of you know the the productive
pressure is placed on them by
capitalists so not it was designed as a
critique of capitalism
I was not designed to as an economic
critique of capitalism he didn't try to
refute any of the economic or
distributed benefits of it but he was
simply describing the effect that doing
things like so if you ask someone what
you do write that question the answer is
what we're gonna not it's that's not
actually what you're asking you're
asking what is your profession and what
pays you money is that what do you do I
wake up in the morning right I go
outside I go for a run I listen to the
birds I like to I like to clip daffodils
and put them in a little pot that's why
I have a my sister has a little poodle
puppy I like to say hello to the puppy
and play fetch for them that's what I do
but the pervasive nature of market
exchange in our society means that when
someone asked what do you do it's really
what do you do for 9:00 to 5:00 so he
examines that in that book and basically
says listen I think a lot of the
anxieties that we have around being
human are derived from the fact that
we're economic animals and we don't
really have a full understanding that
we're economic animals so we're not able
to put distance between ourselves and in
the economics and so it's it's not the
most libertarian book in the world he
doesn't but equally he doesn't call for
in that book he doesn't really call for
government intervention or
redistribution or anything else he's
just saying listen we have to be aware
that these are the consequences of
choosing the way of life that we have
chosen here in the West and it's an
interesting new point for sure believer
in aliens aliens yes little green men no
extraterrestrial life like as a problem
as a matter of probability if you listen
to someone like Max tegmark you know the
math apparently I'm not a mathematician
I'm an attorney but apparently the math
says the universe is infinite and if
that's true it means that somewhere you
know one to the 100 to the 100 meters
from here there are exact copies of us
having the exact same conversation in a
Hubble volume it's identical to our own
so they would be aliens just as much as
you know as a bacterium on Mars in that
respect so I think the math says that
aliens exist but I think the math also
says that we're unlikely to meet them
yeah I think think that's a pretty fair
analysis of the situation after asking
so many people about this one question
here for me to finish oh nothing really
just glad to finally hop on your show
this is awesome you're the first person
not to ask a question you should it'll
work for that
oh hey I don't I don't I don't ask the
questions I'm a big listener so that's a
big listener anyway this is awesome
thank you very much I really appreciate
for sure where can people find you
online I'm Preston J Byrne be why are
any on Twitter and you can find
everything else from there awesome hey I
appreciate very much I think people are
gonna enjoy this there's a lot of
questions circulating around the
constitutional nature of what's going on
in the world so I think this will help
unpack some of it awesome thank you very
much good to talk to you